now then let's get more on today's
announcement of the NHS Workforce plan
labor Shadow Health secretary where
streeting is here with me very good
morning good morning I was talking to
Steve Barkley the health secretary short
while ago talking about this Workforce
plan uh he said it was the most radical
modernization and reform of the
workforce since the NHS was founded the
CEO of the NHS Amanda Pritchard has
called it a truly historic day for the
NHS do you agree with that well for the
best part of a year now I've been
calling on the government to adopt
Labor's Workforce plan for the biggest
expansion of NHS staff in history
doubling the number of medical school
places dramatically increasing nursing
Midwifery clinical Trading Places
and I'm going to pour over the detail
with a fine-tooth comb later today but
this looks remarkably like Labor's plan
so having called on the government to do
it I'm actually relieved that we're in a
position where recruitment will get
underway because we do have an
understaffed NHS I might gently point
out by the way in terms of the historic
comparisons the last Labor government
delivered 75 000 more nurses and 44 000
more doctors
it's crucial because while we need wider
change and modernization the NHS to make
it fit for the future the NHS will
always be a people-based service and so
long as we have a shortage of doctors
nurses midwives and other crucial roles
we will have unacceptable waiting times
patience
I think really frustrated with the NHS
as much as they love the people who work
in it and you know that's why we're in
the situation we're in today which is
the longest waiting times and the lowest
patient satisfaction ever on record in
the NH so you sound like you're pretty
happy with the plan you say that it's
basically your idea so do you give the
government some credit for putting this
into place we hear kissed armor saying
that Rishi sunak is all about
short-termism all the time but he's
really grabbed the nettle here hasn't he
do you give him credit for that I'll
always give the conservative government
credit for listening to the labor
opposition
um but there's a serious point which is
when you think about how long it takes
to train doctors and nurses
four years for a nurse seven years for a
doctor it's really important that
successive governments make the right
decisions and I don't mind admitting
like looking ahead to the next general
election and an incoming labor
government potentially if people vote
for it we are as a team deeply anxious
about what the economy will look like
what our public services will look like
and we're looking at the numbers going
in all the wrong direction at the moment
whether it's inflation interest rates
NHS waiting lists so to see the
government taking a longer term right
correct decision which we've been
calling for of course I would welcome
them okay and the fact that it's long
term gives security to the workforce
doesn't yeah and I want to give that
reassurance to the NHS as well you know
we've got to make sure the numbers stack
up I'm not going to give a government a
blank check here but based on what I've
read so far and I spoke to Steve Barkley
yesterday I'll be questioning him on
Monday in the House of Commons and no
doubt we'll talk in more detail as we as
we would do
you know I think it's important for me
to say to the NHS that we want the
biggest expansion of NHS staff in
history we want to give people the
certainty you know for those one of the
reasons I announced our plan last year
to double the medical school places so I
want to give certainty to those Vice
chancellors and NHS leaders
uh so they can plan ahead yeah we'll
stick to this so if the government is
doing as I expect they are going to do
when the plans announce a doubling
Medical School places and a big
expansion of training I want to say
directly to University Vice Chancellor
today to NHS leaders you can anticipate
an incoming labor government backing the
biggest expansion of NHS Workforce in
history so they've got that certainty
for the years ahead and the government
says that the report the plan rather is
being backed by 2.4 billion pounds of
investment at that funding is only for
five years until the next spending
review though
um if you're in charge will you go ahead
with increased spending and how will you
pay for it yeah well all of us make that
commitment for a parliament we said we'd
fund Ours by abolishing the non-dom tax
status because we think people who make
their make their lives here and they're
living here should pay their taxes here
that seems to be the one bit of our plan
the government haven't adopted you can
ask which is soon that why he's not keen
on abolishing the non-dom tax status but
that that certainty that stability for
the longer term I think is is important
um and and you know I think you've got
to one of the things I want to say to
the NHS Workforce and particularly some
of those Junior doctors who are feeling
pretty miserable about their futures
one of the things about serious
workforce planning you've got to get the
recruitment going and more people into
universities you've also got to make
sure that the pipeline carries through
so you get those Junior doctors moving
into consultant roles so you make sure
that those the wide range of roles we're
going to need for the future are going
to be funded and they're going to be
there and they will be with the labor
government but that funding is important
isn't it but we hear all the time from
the shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves that
no spending will go through without her
strict rules being in place so are you
going to get the money are you going to
have battles with with Rachel Reed
should you get into power
look I'm glad the message has cut
through actually with with Rachel's
discipline around the public finances um
it's true that she runs a tight ship in
the labor party because the public
finances are an absolute binfire at the
moment and there are things that as
labor politicians we would love to be
able to do with that discipline how will
you find the money well assuming the
government's money this instance is
assuming the government's plan is is
funded in the way that I anticipate it
will be I'm going to look at the detail
that'll be in the government's Baseline
which actually as an incoming government
would make our job a bit easier but
we've committed to abolishing the
non-dom tax status so we've got funding
which is committed because and this
you're going to get bored of hearing
this around the election all of our
policies are going to be fully costed
and fully funded that's the tight ship
that Rachel's running and we need to do
that because I want people especially
when they're cynical about politics and
politicians I want people to know when
they pick up our Manifesto and they see
our policies that these are things that
we are certain we can deliver certain we
can afford and a labor government will
under-promise and over deliver which is
both important for the change we want to
bring to our country but also important
for rebuilding trust in politics which
is a very very short supply can I get
thought on this introduction of more
apprenticeships do you have any concerns
about that do you think the unions might
have something to say about this sort of
um a change to traditional roles in the
NHS
I think we've got to consult with the
workforce there's this huge amount of
expertise there but you know I'm I I
grew up on a council estate I'm a kid
from a working class family I think
those roots into Elite professions have
been very powerful and can be even more
powerful for widening participation and
access to Elite professions from a wider
range of backgrounds we've got to look
at all of these routes one of the
reasons why I was a massive fan and a
beneficiary of the last Labor
government's commitment to expanding
access to University education because
in previous decades people like me would
have got a look in my goodness like
going to university has changed my life
I wouldn't be sat on the sofa talking to
you without it we've got to create more
routes and Pathways into Elite
professions and I think we all have
lived through the pandemic and all of us
our lives have been touched or changed
or even saved by the NHS the possibility
of opening the door to more homegrown
talent for a wide range of roles in the
NHS is something we should aspire to it
is the greatest institution this country
has ever built and I want more people to
be able to work in it to work for us and
to build an NHS that's fit for the
future okay we're shooting thanks very
much for coming in this morning thank
you